the video you're about to watch was
described to me as firing cannons at
sparrows
the sparrow being the pretty simple
mathematical problem were about to tell
you about and the cannon being the heavy
artillery the mathematical machinery
that has been used to try to conquer it
now in the middle of the video we will
encounter some of that heavy artillery
but not for too long and stick with us
because at the end you'll encounter a
solution and some numbers you might be
very surprised to see I wanted to sort
of show you a pretty little problem that
I love a lot the problem appears in a
blog by some indian engineer and amateur
mathematician and a kumar who said with
his friend ramana Rao you're given any
polygon and the number let's say we
could take you know our Pentagon doesn't
have to be a regular anything here's the
Pentagon and we take a number
I don't know number six and now we want
to cut this Pentagon into six pieces and
the condition is that the six pieces
have the same area which is easy so for
example if you want to cut it into six
pieces of equal area we could just slide
over and could say you know this is one
six two six three six four five six
drawing isn't good but I think the idea
should work out but these pieces will
have quite different perimeter I think
it's quite obvious that even if we
really make them equal area they will
have different parameter and the
question is whether you know for any
polygon and any number like six I'll try
it again whether there's a different way
to cut it up have something like like
this one to six pieces and we want to
have them equal area and equal perimeter
at the same time it seems that this
should be possible it's not that easy to
work out examples let's say even not a
Pentagon let's take a triangle and you
want to take this triangle and cut it
into three pieces equal area equal
perimeter it's not so clear no actually
there's three mathematicians who then
published a paper in advances in
mathematics proving this problem but
only for this special case of three
pieces and all kinds of machinery
involved and
harmless-looking problem so I think what
we should do here is solve the problem
but for N equals two just to see that
given a polygon why can we cut it into
two pieces of equal area and equal
perimeter so we take a polygon again and
I don't know if there is one and we want
to cut it into T and to piece two pieces
of equal area and equal parameter so the
pieces have to be convex so there's no
in dentin or so so if I cut something
into two pieces of two convex pieces
then this just means cutting by a line
no curved lines are not allowed because
if you use a curved lines then on one
side of the curve it's not connects so
it has to be really straight lines let's
just do a vertical line and I'll do the
vertical line so that we have equal area
let's assume that's it all right but now
I think this left side will have larger
perimeter than the right side okay and
now the trick is what we do is we rotate
this line which means we can rotate it
in such a way that at every single
moment there's the same area on the left
side and on the right side all right and
while we rotate it so the next one will
be here perhaps and next one will be
here always the same area but the
perimeters will change and the perimeter
will change continuously it may be that
on the left side the perimeter gets
larger on the right side it gets smaller
so what we can do is look at the
quantity which just says the perimeter
on the left side minus the perimeter on
the right side and at the beginning with
a vertical line perimeter on the left
side was larger than on the right side
so the difference is positive and now we
rotate and while we rotate the
perimeters change and once we've rotated
180 degrees we have the same vertical
line again but left and right have
interchanged and which means this
difference of perimeter to the left -
perimeter to the right has changed to
its negative value so if in the
beginning this was three inches long
on the left side then in the end it's
three inches longer on the right side
and somewhere in between it must have
been equal end of proof so what have we
used we've used that these quantities
changed continuously and you have to
think about it a bit that if you rotate
the perimeter changes continuously but
that's true and we've used a theorem
that people learn in high school and
capitalist classes called the
intermediate value theorem which just
says that if you have a quantity that
changes from a positive value to a
negative value and if the change is
continuous then somewhere in between you
get zero and my point is that this is
not a theorem of calculus
it's a topology theorem because it's not
important that the quantities change
smoothly and probably they don't it's
only about continuously that's the full
story for N equals two and the problem
is now that for any larger number that
in these configuration spaces of all
possible cuttings let's say in two equal
area they are much more complicated and
by far not as well understood and
there's all kinds of open questions but
it turns out that well now comes the
part where we throw in machinery and the
first part we throw in and machinery is
a theory called optimal transport for us
it tells the following you take a
polygon let's assume I have a bunch of
points in there here's five points and
from optimal transport I get that I can
give weights to these points so that if
I look at the domains of influence would
look something like this so that's what
they call a weight and weighted Voronoi
decomposition there they're always hard
to draw I'm not going to do this
correctly but so I think it will be
something like this this is a partition
associated with these points you see
this is not equal area so I didn't do it
right
but this theorem by contour ovitch and
others says that if I adjust the weights
right so like this point should get more
weight
so in the end its domain that's larger
and perhaps this one should get a
smaller weight and and so you know this
would rather be the domain and if I put
the weights right then I get an equal
area partition that's the theorem and if
I move the points then these unique
weights will move continuously so it's
again continuous and this means that the
space of n distinct points in the
polygon gives me basically a parameter
space for nice partitions of the polygon
into equal area so which means I have
the space doesn't give me all partitions
but it gives me many of them and
actually enough of them this is just the
equal area now we have to get equal
perimeters and that basically means that
for every configuration of points I know
how to get equal area but and now I have
to compare the perimeters and that
basically means I have I get a map from
this space of configurations of points
to a space of values we solve the
problem if we can show that there is no
good map which would never give me all
parameters equal and not all perimeters
equal means basically we mapped the
space of points to the space of values
and we never hit zero which means we
always go around that and now the
question is does that map exist and now
comes the next part it's something that
we take from algebra of topology and
somewhere in there is a theory called a
covariant obstruction theory actually
there's not that much bigger theory it's
it's basically it's a theory which just
consists of one theorem but this one
theorem says that this map doesn't exist
if and only if a certain core homology
class is nonzero so this sounds
amazingly abstract and it is and the
good place to learn a covariant
abstraction theory is a guy is a book by
senior German topology professor Tom Oh
tom deke
it's one of these fat books without a
single picture but very precise I was
called Alice in Wonderland who says
what's the value of a book without
pictures or conversations so there's no
pictures in there there's no
conversations but the theories in there
and I'm not really an algebraic topology
I admire these tools if I want to use it
and I have to make it concrete and I
think I can show you on paper what
really happens there except I'll need a
new sheet of paper for that so we try
and make a concrete which means our
concrete now here means N equals three
again we have a polygon and let's assume
that this is a polygon that we cannot
cut into three pieces of equal area and
equal perimeter so you're assuming that
the whole thing we're trying to do is
impossible yes so proof by contradiction
and now if this is impossible this means
that for any configuration of three
points hmm there's a unique equal area
partition with the right weights but
then I get the values which is these
perimeter one perimeter two perimeter
three the perimeters of these three
pieces and these three parameters are
not equal what we really translate this
in is that we say we have here on the
one hand we have the space of
configurations of three distinct points
and over there we go to something that's
the space of three numbers numbers have
to show up somewhere right because this
is number four and there's three numbers
not all equal and actually we can assume
that this is three numbers which sum to
zero because we just subtract you the
average so if we work out what these
spaces are then in the end it will turn
out that here really we're talking about
maps to a circle
you know from any three numbers that are
not equal you can make a point on the
circle by subtracting the
average which gives you three numbers
that sum to zero and then you divide by
the sum of squares so you get three
numbers for the sum of squares equals
one and that's a circle and now it turns
out that one can understand the space of
configurations of three distinct points
in the plane and basically this space
can be glued together from hexagons
where basically
hexagons could look like this I just
draw one of these hexagons in the end it
will be six of them and the meaning of
this hexagons is basically I can label
this by one two three and one two three
really just means I have three points in
the plane one two and three and point
one is to the left of 0.2 and this is to
the left of 0.3 whereas perhaps this one
here would be 1 3 2 which means again
this is sort of symbolizes 3 points in
the plane but one is to the left of 3
and left of 2 if I look at all
configurations of three points in the
plane then of course it could also
happen that they're just not sorted left
to right but let's say point two is
above point three and this basically
means the space I get will more look
like this and we can work out the
combinatorics of that we're not going to
do the detail on that this here
basically this red line corresponds to
three points but two is above three and
this is again the points one two and
three in the plane but one and two is
below point three so each of the
elements of this space we can sort of
interpret as certain types of point
configurations in the space in the plane
getting a bit too complicated I think
what we'll do is say that now some magic
happens what comes out is that in the
end this map doesn't exist so this map
from
space of configurations of three points
to the space of three numbers that are
not all equal so we have the problem
solved if this map doesn't exist and it
turns out that this is the case if and
only if the following equation does not
have a solution and the equation is one
plus three x plus three y equals zero
and where this X and this Y are supposed
to be integers and just to illustrate
where the threes come from these three
comes from one three is this edges or
these or these it's sort of
combinatorics of the hexagons and the
other thing is the other three edges of
the hexagon but that's sort of that's
where the magic happens and now the
questions does this equation have a
solution in the integers and you stare
at it for a while and you say well
obviously not because if I put in any
integers there I get something that's
divisible by three and I add one and I
get something that's not divisible by
three so we've learned that this
equation does not have a solution which
means the counter example does not exist
which means every polygon can be cut
into three pieces of equal area and
equal perimeter N equals 3 N equals 3
now we get a bit overexcited and we say
if we can do it for N equals 3 turns out
with the same pattern if we take the
equation one plus two x equals zero
that's even easier to see that this
doesn't have a solution right because
this is even plus one is odd doesn't get
zero so this is N equals 2 check which
we already knew even without the missing
details and the magic in the beginning
then we did 1 plus 3 X plus 3 y equals 0
and this doesn't have a solution because
of divisibility by 3 and that solve the
problem
n equals three for N equals four and it
turns out same pattern the hexagon will
be replaced by the permute ahead run
which is wonderful polyhedron to study
and we've solved the problem for n
equals four if this equation doesn't
have a solution one plus four x 6y plus
4z equals zero and you stare at it for a
while and you say well four and six and
four they're all even so if I plug in
any integers there this is even plus one
doesn't give zero which means we've
solved the problem for N equals four we
go on five x + 10 y plus 10 Z plus five
W equals zero does this have a solution
no it doesn't because all of this is
divisible by five which means we've
solved the problem for N equals five and
so on you might hope or guess and that's
not true because the next step is 1 plus
6 X plus 15 y plus 20 z plus 15 W + 6 u
equals 0 so perhaps we should reveal the
mystery what are these numbers that show
up here and it turns out this is
binomial coefficients from Pascal's
triangle and if you don't want to
memorize these numbers actually every
number here is just the sum of the two
numbers above of them that's the rule of
how you do Pascal's triangle so 1 plus 5
is 6 5 plus 10 is 15 10 plus 10 is 20 10
plus 5 is 15 and 5 plus the missing 1 is
6 so that's the pattern which means 6
this is the sixth row of Pascal's
triangle except for a 1 in the end
missing and the question again is now we
are at N equals 6 does this equation
have a solution in the integers and
indeed it does
if you for example put 1
plus 6 times minus 1 sum 1 minus 6 plus
15 times 1 plus 20 times minus 1 and the
rest you take zeros are I think I got it
wrong I take plus 1 here and I take
minus 1 here then I find 1 plus 20 is 6
plus 15 right this means we have a
solution to this equation in integers
which means we do not have a
contradiction which means this map might
exist which means the counter example
might exist so we plainly have not
solved the problem there's not that's N
equals 6 and actually if you continue
and equal 7 again we can solve the
problem easily by the same pattern now
you asked No
so we've solved it for some numbers and
we have not solved it for other numbers
what are the numbers and now magic as we
started this problem this problem came
from India and Akuma and Ramana Rao 2006
now in 1909 in the first issue of the
first volume of the Journal of the math
club and Madras that's where ram anujan
came from there's this paper which
explains to us what we've done here
namely it solved the question for which
values n does the in throw of Pascal's
triangle have a common factor that's
exactly what we were looking at here and
it turns out that always if N is a power
of a prime number we look at this role
and we disregard the ones and we asked
do all these numbers have a common
factor - yes and here the common factor
is 3 and here the common factor is 2 and
here the common factor is 5 and these
numbers don't have a common factor it's
not 2 because this is odd and it's not 3
because this is not divisible by 3 yeah
so this one has a common factor again
namely there
divisible by seven and if we do still
the next one then this is eight and this
is 28 and this is 56 and this is 70 and
fifty-six and twenty eight and eight and
they are all even so it again has a
common factor and that's if we have a
common factor then this original problem
is solved
and what are these numbers so this is
two is a prime number three this is the
brownie numbers your eyes
yes that's the row number so that's row
number two does rule number three three
is also a prime number this is four and
four is not a prime number but it's a
power of a prime it's two squared and
this is five which is again a prime
number and this here is six and 6 is 2
times 3 it's not a prime and it's not a
prime power but it's a product of
different primes and that's where we
don't solve the problem that's Paula
Grahams theorem now 7 again is a prime 8
is 2 times 2 times 2 so it's a prime
power and 9 is 3 squared it's a power of
a prime and 10 is 2 times 5 which means
again we have not solved our problem
going back to a polygon this means we do
not know whether every polygon can be
cut into ten pieces of equal area equal
perimeter it may be possible that this
method that we've used and the whole
machinery and optimal transport and a
covariant obstruction theory in the end
plainly does not answer this problem
still an open problem for 6 for 10 for
12 414 415 for 21 but for these other
values it's solved that's all the values
where it's prime powers I think the
answer is also pretty magical
of course someone at some point has to
solve the problem for the other values
in the moment I don't know how to do
that if you'd like to see more from this
interview I will put it on numberphile
to our second channel there'll be
links on the screen and in the video
description this was filmed at the
mathematical sciences of Research
Institute in Berkeley California where
many of the world's best mathematicians
come to visit and where we at
numberphile film a lot of these
interviews